foreign
hi this is Marcy from Prescott Arizona
regarding episode 354 you say when
you're free from pleasing all the people
you're free from needing all the things
so I'd like to know what your thoughts
are on people Pleasers and caregivers
the intent is different between the two
I think but the actions are quite
similar
I saw this quote and it was written for
caregivers but it reminds me of people
Pleasers and it says it is unsustainable
to live your life in the little spaces
left
in between everyone else's you must tend
to yourself too you must fight back
against a current that pulls your life
into the world
of afterthought
I'm curious your thoughts on these uh
words and the
caregivers and the people Pleasers
and how it all relates to becoming free
from needing all the things
so TK this is one of your quotes
actually once you're free from pleasing
all the people you're free from needing
all the things and I think the things
can be literal things material
possessions here I'd like to get the
essence of what you were talking about
because yes it's true that you can buy a
bunch of things and please people
because now they think a particular way
of you because you have the luxury car
or you have the really nice dress or
you've got the Prada bag or the YSL belt
or whatever it might be yeah and you're
pleasing them in some way but you're
really pleasing yourself at the end of
the day you're pleasing Yourself by
saying look at me I have the status
symbols you can Pat me on the back now
because I've signaled to you that I'm
worthy of your praise but let's expand
on that a little bit when you're free of
pleasing all the people you're
ultimately just free you're free
yeah I mean
every goal requires a level of skill
that is conducive to attaining that goal
if I want to be an MMA fighter then I
have to develop my fighting skill to a
level of Competency that's capable of
holding my ground against other MMA
fighters well what level of skill does
it take to please all the people
that sounds to me so vague that it is
hopelessly immeasurable you truly do
need to do everything to please all the
people and then you become that
flip-flopper you were just talking about
on the previous question right and now
all of a sudden you can't remember your
position on anything because whoever is
in front of you you become a mirror of
that person or that group but even if
you have a small group you can't mirror
everything to please them and you're
going to end up displeasing them you're
going to end up upsetting them it's not
your responsibility to unupset someone
yeah but ultimately they will be upset
because your point of view doesn't match
their point of view and so now you're
going to do these sort of Twister moves
to try to appease everyone you end up
appeasing no one ultimately and you make
yourself miserable in the process that's
right when you need to please everybody
you're living in a constant state of
audience capture where your message your
facial expressions your body language
the words you use the things you laugh
at the music you pretend to like is all
based on the assumptions that you are
making about the person you're talking
to and the predictions you have for how
they may react and you're playing this
game of social chess that is so anxiety
written because first of all how could I
possibly predict with any reasonable
degree of accuracy what you're going to
say in response to what I think and so
not only do I have to get that right but
then I have to do the next step of
pretending to say something pretending
to think something that I don't really
believe that I don't really take
seriously and that's just really a
stressful life and so I don't think the
problem is enjoying the process of
pleasing another human being the problem
is that it's unrealistic to think that
you could do this for everyone so I'll
give an example suppose my great joy in
life is to say hello to people is there
anything wrong with saying hello to
people no but suppose I change that goal
to I want to say hello to all the people
well now I just took something that
gives me joy and I turned it into a goal
that has just set me up for a stressful
life how can I ever be sure that I'm not
missing anyone how can I ever be sure
that everyone's getting my hello right
now instead of focusing on the people
that are around me instead of focusing
on the guy that's right there I've
already said hi to him by the way I'm
I'm reaching for new numbers now I'm
trying to get on YouTube and get a
million followers I'm trying to get a
megaphone to get the other people that
have been driven by I'm not only taking
my attention away from the now and away
from my sphere of influence but I'm
trying to control other areas of life
that are outside of my true locus of
control it's the same way with pleasing
people one of my good friends Isaac
Morehouse said it best decide who you
want to be a hero for and then ignore
everyone else if you want to satisfy
your kids focus on your kids you want to
satisfy your lover focus on your lover
you want to take care of your parents or
you're committed to taking care of them
take good care of them your parents
there is great joy in saying here is a
community where here is a member of my
family where here is a human being here
is a customer that I want to serve by
creating this kind of value for them or
I'm a stand-up comedian for people who
like these kinds of jokes right I'm a
hairdresser for people who like this
kind of style there's great joy in that
but the moment you say
I've got to please them all I've got to
serve them all they all need to be a
customer they all need to be a fan they
all need to be a friend they all need to
be an ally they all need to be someone
who finds me funny someone who finds me
smart interesting nice moral or whatever
it may be
you've lost before you've already begun
and you've taken yourself out of that
Prime wordial state of of doing what
makes you come alive from a place of
self-authenticity did you enjoy this
Standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free